good morning Hank it's Tuesday it's
punishment Tuesday Henry remember how
you came up with this really gross meal
for me tell her carrots will feed you
and gross barbecue with me Jill gross
barbecue with me drool grow slobber
carrots with me drool and hat now we'll
see you know you your drool hmm I would
prefer my drool micros already in my
mouth couple questions Henry first off
what are slobber carrots are cooked
carrot okay that doesn't sound too bad
and then barbecue is basically just meat
and barbecue sauce right may I gotta say
so far the only gross part of this
sounds like it's gonna be your gruel
yeah I love to know uh-oh
Henry what do you think luncheon wolf is
gonna taste like you know like goo
they're so focused on value they didn't
even spend the money to print the e and
value okay so we're making soccer
carrots first thing you need to do is
preheat the oven Henry what temperature
should we preheat the oven to - five 425
sounds good
I wonder if mom helped you out with that
and you take all the salt and pepper
Henry you want to mr. salt or mr. pepper
okay
this is coming fairly well-seasoned
slobber carrots here buddy okay I think
it's definitely enough Henry do you want
to go ahead and drool on the carrots now
or after they're cooked it's a meat like
product and then it should just oh oh
god that looks horrible
it just looks delicious you don't have
something interesting Henry the first
ingredient of value time luncheon loaf
is mechanically separated chicken comma
pork and then the last ingredient is
smoke flavoring I didn't know that was
an ingredient how does it smell Henry
yeah so what you want to do now is you
want to cut a couple slices of value
time lunch and move I am NOT looking
forward to having that in my body you
want to cook it over a low heat and also
it's time to put in the slaughter
carrots all right
oh we need a hat then
should we make a hat out of cash that's
a great idea so Henry when you're making
a cabbage at the key is to let mom cut
the cabbage for all ii control claw
here's my cabbage chat oh yeah are you
ready for my cabbage hat trick oh oh
I did it so once your luncheon loaf is
reasonably browned you put it on a plate
of its own all right Henry it's time to
put on the barbecue sauce
isn't that enough oh don't mine
and of course the last ingredient Henry
is drool oh just a tiny little
sprinkling of drool lastly you're gonna
want to take your slobber carrots out of
the oven we're ready to eat you take a
peek at what BAM then you take your
barbecue with value time luncheon loaf
of ends that looks delicious and on top
go the slobber carrots first I'm going
to try the slobber carrots with the
drool
it's actually quite good but anything
the dual adds something whereas barbecue
with drool okay
so bad
oh so much worse than a blender eyes
happy Oh God
what about hat I'll have a little bit
hat oh it's okay oh not very good so
there you have an egg that was my
punishment meal I don't recommend it it
was to quote Henry the grossest meal
ever
I'll see you on Friday